thank you for joining us for the news  here at noon everyone i'm alex backus we  begin with that breaking news and it is  big news from the cdc  just a few moments ago the agency  announced americans who are  fully vaccinated against coven 19 no  longer need to wear masks or  socially distance from others indoors  and outdoors in most cases  however masks will still be required in  crowded settings indoors  that would include public transportation  and hospitals this new guidance comes as  an aggressive vaccination campaign  is paying off across the country cases  right now at their lowest rate since  september  of last year and deaths are at their  lowest point since last  april so some really good news